after years as a rebel hussein
al-muhajir is back in the chatting
capital in germany a member of the armed
group national concord movement his
faction was one of more than 40 which
recently signed a peace agreement with
the government
we saw through the negotiations that
lasted for five months but the best
options for us as a political armed
group is peace
there is no better option the conflict
has been going on for a long time and
many people have been
affected the deal between chad's
military government and the armed groups
signed in qatar's capital doha have led
to talks on the country's political
future they're scheduled to start on
saturday after years of turmoil a crisis
that worsened last year when mohammed
idris debbie took power after the death
of his father defying the constitution
the talks are said to last for up to
three weeks among the issues to be
discussed are the constitution and the
timeline for national elections while
many groups are expected to take part in
the dialogue others have rejected it
including the main armed group front for
change and conquered which fought in the
battle against the government last year
that killed then-president idris debbie
the government says it hopes those not
taking part in the talks will join soon
this is the first time we're having an
inclusive dialogue that includes
political parties and civil societies
and where the armed groups are not there
for one-on-one agreements the doha
agreement paved the way for this the
door is still open for those who have
not signed to join in the talks
the years of conflict have taken a toll
on civilians bushara ahmed is a survivor
of fighting between government and rebel
groups in the capital in 2008
we didn't walk on the street there were
bodies everywhere of soldiers or rebels
or innocent people we had to flee to a
town far away where we struggled with
food and water because there are too
many of us so i hope these stocks bring
stability
with nearly half the population living
in poverty and hundreds of thousands
still displaced many others also share
the same hopes even if some have refused
to join the process for peace hiba
morgan al jazeera in jamaica